hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and in this video
I will be breaking down the quirks and
special abilities of all 20 class 1a
students including all of their updates
and upgrades as of the final Arc in the
mha manga one of the very first mha
videos that we did here on the channel
was a video explaining all the quirks in
class 1a but that was over five years
ago and things have changed drastically
some quirks have changed completely
others have become much stronger and
others still turned out to be quirks
that were stolen from other people and
we even got the long-awaited face
reveals for toru hagakure and meso Shoji
so yeah there is a lot to talk about
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy our videos and you
want to support us leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps us out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you're one of
the over 50 of people who watch our
video videos regularly but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free it's
literally just a click or two but it's
actually very important finally this
video will contain all the latest
spoilers about the 20 quirks in class 1a
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned first up let's talk about
the student who sits in seat number one
Yuga aoyama also known as The Shining
hero can't stop twinkling and his Quirk
Naval laser although spoiler alert it's
not actually his Quirk Naval laser is an
emitter type Quirk that enables its user
to fire twinkly but powerful laser beams
from his belly button the laser beam is
quite strong and we've seen it easily
destroying hard surfaces like metal and
concrete that said this is is a Shonen
Series so we've also seen the lasers
being aimed directly at yuga's opponents
and yet those who were attacked managed
to survive they weren't like game over
on the spot or anything like that Yuga
does have some ability to control the
power of His laser attacks for example
his ultimate move called Supernova
requires him to charge his Naval laser
for at least five seconds and after that
he can release a significantly more
powerful laser attack than the attacks
he normally uses the Quirk can be pretty
versatile if you know how to control it
it is able to attack from short mid and
long range distances and the user can
also use the laser to fly through the
air by aiming the laser into the ground
or another surface the user can also
alter the shape and size of the laser
beam that is being used it can be
extremely thin or it can be as wide as
an entire person and it can even be
turned into a blade of Light which can
then be used as a saber-like weapon in
fact this is one of yuga's ultimate
moves called Naval saber this Quirk can
also be very practical in dark
environments because the bright light it
produces can be used to light up the
surrounding area it can even be used to
send a powerful signal into the air as a
way to inform your allies of your
location or as a way to lure your
enemies into a trap but even though
Naval laser is a pretty powerful and
versatile Quirk it also has some serious
drawbacks especially for Yuga in
particular as we learned in chapter 336
of the manga Yuga aoyama was actually
born quirkless meaning that Naval laser
did not originally belong to him Naval
laser was actually given to Yuga by the
arch villain all for one himself after
yuga's parents made a deal with all for
one because they didn't want their son
to be a quirkless outcast as we know all
for one has the ability to steal the
quirks of others and transfer them
either to himself or to other people and
Naval laser is a stolen Quirk that he
transferred to Yuga however Yuga his
body had a tough time adapting to the
sudden appearance of a quirk and so the
power of Naval laser began accidentally
leaking out of his belly button even if
he didn't want it to as a result he had
to start wearing a special belt called
the sparkle belt at all times in order
to prevent his Naval laser from bursting
out uncontrollably on top of being
difficult to control Naval laser also
has limitations in terms of how much of
its power can be used at once if Yuga
continues using the laser for more than
a second his insides can become damaged
and he can even lose control of his
bowels initially he is only able to fire
the laser from one place in his body his
belly button as a result he was always
forced to face his opponent directly
when engaging in battle and he was
vulnerable to attacks from behind and
from the sides Yuga eventually acquires
a hero costume that allows him to
channel the power of Naval laser and
send it to other parts of his body which
then enables him to launch laser beams
from his knees and shoulders as well is
from his belly button
in seat number two we have Mina ashido
also known as Pinky and her Quirk acid
now Mina has a very unique appearance
her skin is pinkish she has horns on her
head and the white of her eyes is
actually black this may lead some to
conclude that she has a mutant type
Quirk but her Quirk is actually
classified as emitter that's because her
Quirk is not a byproduct of a mutation
rather her unique appearance is in part
a byproduct of her Quirk it's a bit
confusing but we gotta just roll with it
the Quirk classifications are not as
precise as people might think acid is a
medium range Quirk that enables its user
to generate an acid-like corrosive
substance from her skin Mina can produce
the acid from any part of her skin and
she is able to manipulate the quantity
and the trajectory of the fluid her acid
is quite strong and it can corrode even
strong substances like metal
she herself is resistant to the effects
of her Quirk so her acid will not harm
her however if Mina overuses her Quirk
and produces too much acid in a short
period of time her skin will eventually
stop being resistant and she will hurt
herself Mina is aware of this limitation
and she is trained hard to make her skin
more durable she's also worked
tirelessly to control her Quirk so as
not to accidentally harm anyone that
said accidents can still happen so she
has to wear a special acid-proof hero
costume so as not to accidentally burn
her own clothes off in the middle of a
battle as Mina's training progresses she
is able to control the thickness and
texture of her acid this means that she
can make it more or less harmful to
other living beings depending on what
her objective is and she can use it for
other interesting purposes such as
creating a thick defensive barrier or
using it to climb walls by having the
acid burn holes into the walls that she
could then grab onto she can even
release acid from her feet and make the
floor slippery which then increases her
maneuverability because it allows her to
skate or Glide across the floor she can
also quickly burn holes in walls and
floors in order to gain access to a
particular location and she can even use
an ultimate move called acid man which
essentially allows her to coat her
entire body inside a thick acidic armor
even though Mina's Quirk is a pretty
simple concept producing acid from your
skin the more we learn about it the more
we realize how useful and versatile this
Quirk can be it has offensive
capabilities defensive capabilities and
it helps with maneuverability and
infiltration and of course part of the
reason why this Quirk turned out to be
so strong and versatile is Mina herself
she is fiercely committed to her
training and hard work pays off in seat
number three we have tsuyu asui also
known as the rainy season hero froppy
the name of her Quirk is frog and it is
actually classified as a mutant type
Quirk tsuyu was born as a human with the
biological traits of a frog including
incredibly strong legs that allow her to
hop through the air the ability to cling
to walls the ability to secrete mucus
that produces various different effects
including paralysis a strong and
extremely long frog-like tongue that can
stretch for like 20 meters the ability
to swim faster than any human the
ability to use camouflage and so on
basically tsuyu has the ability to do
everything that a frog is able to do
although to be fair she can actually use
the abilities of a variety of different
species of frog she further enhances her
ability through vigorous physical
training so unlike Mina whose Quirk is
the ability to produce acid and then
this Quirk Alters her physical
appearance as her body adapts to The
Quirk itself tsuyu's frog-like Anatomy
is what gives her all of her abilities
in the first place so her actual Anatomy
me is her Quirk that is why it's a
mutant type Quirk as you'd expect from
someone who has the biological makeup of
a frog tsuyu is adversely affected by
extreme cold temperatures because frogs
are cold-blooded and they cannot
function in extremely cold conditions
along with extreme cold tsuyu also isn't
good with extreme heat because frogs are
aquatic creatures so they can't function
in excessively hot and dry conditions
but despite the quirk's weaknesses and
limitations frog is one of the most
versatile quirks in mha it allows for
superhuman speed agility and
maneuverability in fact Deku taught
himself to release black whip from his
mouth in the same way that tsuyu
releases her giant tongue and he calls
this move froppy style as an homage to
to you in seat number four is class
representative Tenya Eda AKA turbo hero
ingenium and his Quirk engine engine is
another mutant type Quirk because Tanya
was actually born with engine parts
inside the calves of his legs and this
allows Tanya to move extremely quickly
and reach incredible speed no I'm no
mechanic or biologist but I guess having
Mufflers on your calves would make you a
really fast runner I'm sure that's how
human anatomy and mechanical engines
work so we don't need to question it
needless to say having the ability to
achieve super speed is very useful in
battle and it is also useful if you need
to get somewhere in a hurry like if
someone needs to be rescued and time is
of the essence and let's be real super
speed is also useful if you just want to
run away from a stronger enemy before
they can take you out I mean that is
literally the Joe Star Family secret
technique as explained by the greatest
JoJo of all time Joseph joestar along
with speed tenya's Quirk also gives him
superhuman leg strength which allows him
to deliver overpowered kicks that are
strong enough to destroy even hard
substances like metal a lot of these
guys can just Crush metal metal is
nothing in the world of mha just like a
car engine tenya's engine Quirk has
different gears and he can switch
between those gears depending on how
much speed and power he requires at any
given time in terms of those Mufflers
that are sticking out of tenya's legs
they can actually be forcibly removed
which is an extremely painful procedure
but if they are removed new ones will
eventually grow in their place and these
new ones will be even more powerful if
the user continues to push his limits
through rigorous training thereby
forcing them to adapt to these new
levels of power just like real engines
Tanya's engines require some sort of
fuel to function and for Tenya this fuel
is actually orange juice he needs to
consume enough orange juice to use his
Quirk properly and if he doesn't his
clerk will eventually progressively get
weaker and then stop working altogether
Tanya must also refrain from consuming
carbonated drinks like soda because
carbonated drinks causes engines to
stall on top of that Tanya has to make
sure that no one blocks or clogs his
Mufflers in any way because this would
hinder his ability to use his Quirk
Tanya's older brother tensei also
possesses the same Quirk although his
engines are on his elbows rather than on
his calves The Quirk seems to function
in essentially the same way for both
brothers both can use the same ultimate
move known as reciproced which allows
the user to produce a brief but massive
burst of speed this burst will last for
only about 10 seconds and after the end
of the 10 seconds the engines will be
incapacitated for a while but if used
wisely those 10 seconds can give Tenya
an important upper hand over his
opponent in battle later on after
removing and regenerating his Mufflers
Tenya able to unlock a move called
recipro turbo which allows him to
drastically increase his speed for 10
whole minutes rather than just 10
seconds recipro turbo is even faster
than other moves like reciprocal burst
and reciprocal extend and it is said to
even surpass Gran Torino's Quirk jet
when it comes to speed
in seed number five we have ochako
uraraka AKA uraviti and her emitter type
Quirk zero uravity I mean zero gravity
ocheko has these little pads on the tips
of her fingers and her Quirk allows her
to essentially remove the gravity around
anything or anyone that she touches with
those pads as the quirk's name suggests
the person or object that ochako touches
instantly begins to experience zero
gravity and becomes weightless as long
as she touches something that is under
three tons in weight ochako can make it
float in midair and she can choose to
activate or cancel out the effects of
her Quirk by pressing her fingertips
together at first every time ochako used
The Quirk on herself in order to make
herself float she would become nauseous
and vomit she trained hard in zero
gravity conditions in order to reduce
this side effect and she has been
successful in managing it over time she
she also trained hard to learn to
control her Quirk and to make good use
of it during fights and evacuations
ochako has trained martial arts so that
she can use them alongside her quirk in
order to be more effective in combat and
if she could get close enough to touch
her Target and make the opponent float
this is usually very effective in terms
of disorienting the opponent and taking
them out of the battle that said
ochako's Quirk does require her to make
direct physical contact with her Target
which means that she usually needs to
get up close and personal to her
opponent so she often has to put herself
in dangerous situations in order to
touch her Target directly as a result
villains with good long-range quirks
have a decisive advantage over ochako
but ochako is able to make good use of
the battlefield itself like for example
she can touch a bunch of heavy Rubble
floated up into the air and then drop it
down on potential opponents this skill
can also be used to rescue people who
might be stuck beneath debris and Rubble
by lifting it up and then evacuating
them to safety ochako is a great team
player and her core can be used very
effectively in conjunction with other
quirks for instance she can make herself
and her allies float and if anyone has a
quirk that can propel them forward they
will effectively be flying at Great
speeds thanks to zero gravity another
example of her team game is the move
meteor fafrotskies in which ochako uses
Zero Gravity on herself tsuyu and a
bunch of debris tsuyu then uses her
tongue to launch the floating debris
directly at their opponents on the
ground while the two of them are still
safely in the air ocheko has a whole
bunch of named ultimate moves but they
all revolve around making either people
or objects or both float in some way
in seat number six we have mashirao
ojiro whose hero name is tail man and
whose Quirk name is simple and to the
point tail ojiro's Quirk is a mutant
type Quirk that grants its user a long
and Powerful tale that can be used as an
additional appendage on his body the
tail itself is extremely strong it can
break metal objects it can support
ojiro's entire weight if he wants to
hang by his tail and it can be used as
an effective way to restrain opponents
by wrapping the tail around them ojiro
has worked very hard to make his tail
stronger and more resilient through
training for example he practiced
hitting kirishima's hardened body over
and over again in order to increase the
strength and durability of his tail it
is important to note that ojiro is a
trained martial artist and he uses his
Mastery of martial arts in combination
with his Quirk to make himself a
powerful and effective fighter not only
is ojiro able to use his tail as an
addition appendage with which to attack
an opponent but he can also use it to
propel himself in various directions he
can use it to suspend himself from
elongated structures like pipes by
wrapping his tail around them and so on
tail has two named ultimate moves the
first is tornado tail dance which
involves ojiro launching himself at an
opponent spinning in the air and
smashing everything around him with his
powerful tail the second is swamp smack
spin which involves ojiro stretching out
his tail and spinning horizontally
allowing him to drive away everything
and everyone around him since tail is a
permanent part of ojiro's body it can at
times restrict his movements when
compared to other humans I mean imagine
having to sleep every night with that
massive tail permanently attached to you
that would definitely take some getting
used to and of course because this Quirk
is just an additional physical appendage
tail is vulnerable to all forms of
potential physical damage just like a
normal leg or arm seat number seven is
occupied by the one and only denki
kaminari also known as the stun gun hero
charge bolt kaminari has an emitter type
Quirk called electrification and it
enables him to charge himself up with
electricity and then release that
electricity from his body to either
attack an opponent or defend himself
from an opponent's attack using the
Quirk will produce both electricity and
the light and it has the ability to
paralyze those who come into direct
contact with that electric energy in the
real world a strong electric discharge
can of course kill people but since this
is Shonen coming on his Quirk just
leaves his targets paralyzed initially
kaminari doesn't really have control
over the electricity that he releases
and so everyone who is close to him when
he uses his Quirk is affected by it
including both allies and enemies but
thanks to the work of the UA support
department kaminari's hero costume was
eventually equipped with sharp shooting
gear created by hatsume and power loader
Sharp Shooting gear is a support item
that allows kaminari to actually aim his
electric discharges so that they won't
negatively affect the people around him
who are not his targets kaminari has a
device on his right arm which allows him
to fire off discs in whichever direction
he pleases these discs will then stick
to the point of impact and as long as
kaminati remains within 10 meters of the
intended target the electricity that he
discharges will be drawn directly to the
disc and surged towards it in a straight
line instead of discharging wildly all
around him he can even Target multiple
points of impact by using a dial on his
shooter and calculating the locations of
the various points of impact using his
special glasses it's all really cool
complicated Tech stuff very cyberpunk in
addition to attacking and defending with
his Quirk kaminari can use electric
discharges to power electronic devices
making him a great friend to him around
when you forget your smartphone charger
but even though electrification is both
powerful and and useful it also has some
significant drawbacks at its core
electrification is a close range Quirk
and the further away you try to
discharge it the less effective it
becomes on top of that there is a limit
to how much electric power kaminari can
actually discharge if he surpasses his
limit he will essentially short-circuit
his own brain and this turns him into a
useless Derpy mess for about an hour
during that one hour period he can't
really use his Quirk to do much of
anything so he becomes nothing but dead
weight on the battlefield and while his
Derpy mode is a great meme it is a very
serious setback in battle if he's not
careful this weakness could jeopardize
coming out his life and the life of his
allies if it happened at the wrong time
kaminari's Quirk will also be rendered
ineffective whenever he runs into
materials that don't conduct electricity
so for example if kaminari tried to
fight Luffy he would be completely red
effect electrification has a number of
ultimate moves including indiscriminate
shock 1.3 million volts which involves
coming out of discharging a bunch of
electricity all around him and shocking
everyone that is close to him this is
obviously a useful attack when you are
surrounded by enemies but it is less
useful when you are also in the vicinity
of your own allies he can also use
indiscriminate Shock 2 million volts
which is essentially the same as the
previous ultimate move but the voltage
is higher due to the higher voltage this
attack is more likely to short-circuit
kaminari's brain finally kaminari has a
move called Target electo this move
refers to kaminari using his Sharp
Shooting gear to fire off a powerful
charge of electricity towards his Target
in a straight line
seat number eight belongs to our boy
ajiro kirishima AKA The sturdy hero Red
Riot the name of his Quirk is hardening
it's a transformation type Quirk and it
allows him to harden his body either all
of it or a select part that he chooses
such as an arm once hardened kirishima's
body becomes both tough and sharp so it
can be used both defensively and
offensively in terms of Defense
kirishima's hardened body can withstand
explosions falling rubble and even
bullets without suffering damage in
terms of offense kirishima's hardening
greatly increases the power of His
attacks and he is able to destroy
powerful objects like metal with a
single blow again all of these guys can
just Crush metal metal doesn't stand a
chance in addition kirishima can
actually increase the strength of his
Quirk by training it and that is exactly
what he does during his training
sessions with ojiro the more damage
kirishima takes on in training the more
his hard editing can adapt and become
even more durable in the future
hardening first manifested when
kirishima was three years old and
initially it was a much weaker Quirk
than it is now kirishima's ability to
harden his body to the extent that he is
able to now is a result of intense
training and hard work it's not just
natural talent but with all of that said
hardening isn't Without Limits and if
kirishima takes on enough damage his
hardening will eventually wear off so if
he's facing a particularly powerful and
Relentless opponent his Quirk could give
out and he could be defeated needless to
say hardening is a short-range quirk
with no long-range capabilities the user
must get up close and personal with his
opponent in order to use the Quirk for
offensive purposes although the
defensive aspects of hardening can still
be used against an opponent with long
range attacks finally even though
hardening protects kirishima from nearly
all physical damage his body will still
feel the effects of extreme hot or
extreme cold if he's facing an opponent
with like a Firebase Quirk or an
ice-based quirk in such situations his
body will be immune to physical damage
but it could still be vulnerable to
other side effects that come with being
exposed to extreme cold or heat
kirishima has a number of ultimate moves
including red counter which allows him
to withstand a close range attack from
an opponent and then immediately
counter-attack with a hardened punch
there's also Red Riot unbreakable which
allows kirishima to reach the absolute
maximum of his hardening abilities his
entire body becomes rugged and hard
almost like a jagged cliff in this form
kirishima is practically indestructible
but he can only maintain it for about 30
or 40 seconds nevertheless even if he is
unable to end the fight while in this
form and he is forced to return to
normal kirishima can still eventually
come back and keep fighting which is an
ability that he demonstrated in his
fight against arapa kirishima's third
named ultimate move is red gauntlet lit
which involves kirishima rushing the
enemy and smashing them with a single
overpowered punch on top of being a
great Quirk for hand-to-hand combat
hardening is also very useful for a hero
to have in evacuation situations that's
because the user can smash through
Rubble in order to get to civilians who
may be stuck inside and then rescue them
he can also use this hardened body as a
human shield in order to protect
innocent civilians from potential
attacks next up we have Koji Koda aka
the petting hero anima who sits in seat
number nine he has an emitter type Quirk
called anavois and this Quirk enables
him to communicate directly with animals
and also to tell them what to do the
animals will then obey his orders and do
his bidding he doesn't seem to be able
to have a complex conversation with an
animal like he would with another human
but he can definitely give information
to animals and they can also pass
information back to him Coda squirk
allows him to make use of all sorts of
animals from tiny insects to large
beasts and from burrowing rodents to
high-flying birds we don't know if
animals have the power to disobey Coda
but so far they have always complied
with his orders this could be because
they genuinely like Coda because he is
very nice to them and he is clearly an
animal lover or it could just be that
The Quirk actually compels them to obey
even though humans are technically also
animals and a voice does not work on
humans it also doesn't work on any
artificial creatures such as robots
because the Quirk works on the basis of
sound if Coda is unable to speak for
whatever reason the Quirk will not work
furthermore if another Quirk can produce
a loud noise that drowns out and a voice
then it will also lose its Effectiveness
like many others Koda is able to make
his Quirk stronger through training in
particular he is able to do vocal cord
exercises that increase the range of his
Quirk making it possible to control
animals that are far away from him and
not just animals that are like right
beside it he also uses a voice amplifier
as part of his hero costume which also
increases the range of his Quirk at
first Coda didn't want to use his Quirk
on insect because he was afraid of them
but he has been working through that
fear in chapter 372 Coda undergoes a bit
of a transformation he grows horns on
his head which is something that his
mother had told him would happen when he
reaches maturity and after that occurs
his Quirk becomes more powerful and its
range increases even further Coda has
two named ultimate moves including
Hitchcock Birds which involves Koda
summoning a swarm of birds and using
them against an opponent the name of
this move is a reference to the movie
The Birds by Alfred Hitchcock his second
ultimate move is bugging out which
involves Koda summoning bugs and insects
and then getting them to swarm his
opponent seed number 10 belongs to
rikido Sato also known as the sweet hero
Sugar Man the name of his Quirk is sugar
rush it is an emitter type Quirk and it
enables its user to suddenly become five
times stronger than he is normally this
lasts for a period of three minutes for
every 10 grams of sugar that he consumes
The Quirk is pretty straightforward it
is a temporary power boost fueled by
unhealthy amounts of sugar and Sato must
consume this sugar before his Quirk will
activate if he doesn't have access to
Sugar Sato cannot use his Quirk and
there is also a drawback to using it
after using Sugar Rush Sato will
experience a sugar crash and this will
result in the lowering of his cognitive
ability and intelligence as well as
sluggishness and the lack of energy Sato
is a close range fighter and he uses his
Quirk to punch his way through opponents
while the effects of the sugar last his
hero costume includes a belt that holds
sugar containers which he can then
consume when he needs them his only
named move is also called Sugar Rush and
it's basically just him consuming sugar
and then rushing his opponent and
punching him over and over again and
screaming
but yeah he's basically a JoJo's
character in seed number 11 we have
mezzo Shoji also known as the tentacle
hero tentacle a character who was a
mystery for most of the series but who
finally got some excellent character
development in the final Arc Shoji has a
mutant type Quirk called duply arms he
was born with fleshy arm-like tentacles
attached to his body and his Quirk
enables him to essentially duplicate
parts of his body and produce them on
these tentacles the duplicate body parts
are improved versions of The Originals
which allows Shoji to increase both his
strength and his senses when using the
Quirk if any of the replicated parts are
damaged or cut off Shoji can still
replace them again later that said he
will feel pain when the duplicated body
parts are injured and it takes some time
to heal those injuries Shoji is able to
make his duplicate body parts stronger
and more effective through training and
his Quirk is actually very versatile
with many diverse uses his ability to
produce high-powered eyes and ears in
various places on his body make him
great at Gathering Intel spying and
stakeouts he can create many artificial
arms on his body which he can then use
to deliver a barrage of incredibly
strong punches on his opponent he can
also use his arms and tentacles to
create a protective cocoon around people
and then carry them out of Harm's Way
which has got great ability to have when
evacuating civilians because of the
webbed design of his duply arms Shoji
can even use them to glide through the
air for a brief period of time by
spreading them open as if they were a
large pair of wings Shoji has several
named ultimate moves including octoblow
which allows him to create multiple arms
at once and then unleash an array of
fast-paced and overpowered punches at
his opponent he also has a move called
octo Searcher which allows him to create
multiple artificial eyes and ears
throughout his body in order to gather
as much Intel as possible within a short
period of time and in the final Arc of
the story Shoji revealed a new move
called
octospanchion which allows him to
transform his tentacle-like arm into a
gigantic fist that he can then use to
deliver a super powered punch to his
opponent due to the mutant type nature
of his Quirk Shoji has an unconventional
physical appearance along with his
unique tentacle-like arms he also has a
face that looks different from what an
average human face looks like initially
Shoji kind of implied that he wore a
mask all the time because his face was
particularly grotesque or disturbing but
that is not actually the case when he
does finally reveal his face we see that
although it looks elongated and
unconventional his face is by no means
ugly or disturbing he does however have
multiple scars across his face which
were given to him by bullies who
attacked him just because he had a
mutant type Quirk Shoji had an extremely
tough childhood and he faced serious
hardship because of the nature of his
Quirk but he persevered and became a
truly impressive and admirable hero
seat number 12 is occupied by kyokajiro
also known as the hearing hero earphone
jack she has a mutant type Quirk which
is also called earphone jack giro's
earlobes are basically long earphone
cables that she can control and
manipulate there is a jack at the end of
each earlobe and Jiro is able to plug
these Jacks into various objects
including electronic equipment if she
channels the vibration of her heartbeats
into her cable-like earlobes she can
actually damage the objects that she
comes into contact with she can also use
the earlobes to hear what's happening on
the other side of large walls so kind of
like Shoji she is well suited for
scouting and reconnaissance missions
although amazing for support and spying
because it can detect enemy movements
through vibrations and things of that
nature earphone Jack's natural offensive
abilities are limited compared to some
of the other quirks that we've covered
but with that said giro's earlobes are
able to expand to a length of about 6
meters and they are also surprisingly
strong Jiro can use them to actually
pick up objects and even to pierce
through strong materials like concrete
thanks to a wide variety of special
equipment and support items she has been
able to enhance her offensive
capabilities for example she is now able
to plug her Jacks into the boots of her
hero costume and then amplify the
vibrations of her heartbeat in order to
create a sound wave that she can direct
at an opponent these sound waves can
also be used to counter enemy attacks
like when Jiro uses an attack called
counterbalance to counter the effects of
present Mike's sound based Quirk Giro
can also use special amplifier items on
her forearms to create a powerful
vibration that causes the ground itself
to shatter an attack known as heartbeat
Distortion once again this is
accomplished by plugging her Jacks into
the amplifier items and then channeling
and amplifying the vibration of her
heartbeat through these items Jiro
eventually learns to use her amplifying
equipment in such a way that it sends
powerful sound waves Direct directly at
her opponents and her other named moves
include heartbeat surround Legato and
heartbeat wall so overall jiro's Quirk
can be quite useful and versatile
although it does rely heavily on support
items in addition if Jiro overuses her
Quirk her ears will begin to bleed and
because earphone jack is a mutant type
Quirk that is literally a part of giro's
physical body if the earlobes were
physically damaged then Judo wouldn't be
able to use her Quirk anymore
next let's talk about the student who
occupies seat number 13 the flex tape
Spider-Man himself haunta Cerro also
known as the taping hero cellophane
Cerro has a mutant type Quirk called
tape and it enables him to eject sticky
tape from his elbows this tape can be
extremely long and it sticks to the
surfaces it touches the tape is also
extremely strong and it can be used to
restrain opponents support sero's own
weight and the weight of others rapidly
climb buildings and other objects and
generally to move around like a flex
tape Spider-Man the amount of tape that
Cerro can generate is not unlimited and
he has to train hard in order to
increase the amount of tape that he can
use as well as the strength and speed of
the tape itself Cerro takes full
advantage of the long range capabilities
of his Quirk by firing tape from a
distance at his opponents hitting them
with the tape and then wrapping the tape
around them in order to restrain them he
has developed great aim over the course
of his training and he can even fire
multiple strands of tape at the same
time he can also produce double-sided
tape that sticks on both sides and that
can be used to create sticky traps for
opponents because of its versatility
tape is a great work to use in
combination with other quirks as part of
a team battle and we've seen both minata
and ochako making use of cerro's tape in
combination with their own quirks Cerro
has a couple of named moves including
barricade tape which involves them
surrounding an entire area with tape to
protect the area itself from Surprise
enemy attacks and there's also Trident
which involves Cerro grabbing objects
with his tape and then throwing them at
his opponent Trident is especially
effective when used in combination with
ochakos Quirk because she can use zero
gravity to allow Cerro to launch
incredibly heavy objects like Boulders
that he would never have been able to
pick up otherwise as is the case with
many quirks tape does have some
drawbacks if it is overused in cerro's
case overejecting his tape will lead to
dry skin on top of that while seto's
tape is certainly sturdy it is not
unbreakable and a strong opponent can
simply cut or break through it
in seat number 14 we have the legendary
feathered Batman the emo bird boy the
chicken of Darkness fumikage tokoyami
okay his official hero name is the jet
black hero tsukuyomi but I prefer
chicken of Darkness tokuyami's Quirk is
called Dark Shadow and it is a
long-range emitter type Quirk this Quirk
basically gives you access to a stand
from JoJo's by which I mean that a
bird-like monster that seems to be
formed from Shadows appears out of the
user's own body even though this
creature looks like a shadow it has a
real physical presence and it can do
some real physical damage the creature
is sentient and even capable of speaking
it is permanently attached to its host
tokoyami and it protects him from harm
it also obeys his orders at least most
of the time although the creature known
as dark shadow is always connected to
tokuyami's body it is also able to
extend itself far beyond his body it has
its own senses and Sensations separate
from the host body and it can even speak
telepathically with its host it
possesses immense physical power and it
is also highly resistant which means
that it can be used both for attacking
an opponent and for shielding the host
against attacks later on in the story
and thanks to the guidance of hawks
tokuyami figures out a way to use dark
shadow to essentially fly through the
air which greatly boosts his
maneuverability the power of dark shadow
is weakened by the presence of light and
quirks that work on the bases of light
are more effective against it at the
same time though when there is no Light
present like during the night Dark
Shadow becomes much bigger and stronger
at times like this it is even prone to
going berserk especially if tokuyami is
feeling intense emotions that he is
struggling to control but although
berserk mode Dark Shadow can be
difficult to control it is also much
much stronger than it is during the day
and this is no understatement berserk
mode Dark Shadow is easily one of the
strongest quirks in the entire series
Dark Shadow has a whole bunch of named
ultimate moves including black abyss
piercing Twilight claws black Fallen
Angel Sabbath fleeting blow and more I
can't talk about them all because if I
do we'll be here forever but it is
important to note that a move called
Ragnarok appears to allow tokoyami to
use dark shadow in its overpowered
Berserker form without losing control of
it throughout the series tokuyami has
worked extremely hard to train his Quirk
and better control his power and towards
the end of the series all that hard work
really starts to pay off
seed number 15 belongs to Shoto Todoroki
the son of number one Pro Hero Endeavor
and the user of an extremely unique work
called half cold half hot his hero name
is literally just Shoto so yeah let's
just call him Shoto shoto's work is a
unique mix of his parents quirks and
because his mother has a powerful
ice-based Quirk and his father has a
powerful Firebase Quirk Shoto was born
with the ability to generate both ice
and fire specifically the right side of
his body could create ice Frost and
extreme cold while the left side of his
body can produce fire flames and heat
shoto's work is therefore the perfect
marriage of Ice and Fire which makes it
rare powerful and extremely versatile at
first Shoto only wanted to use the
eyesight of his Quirk because he had a
very poor relationship with his father
and he didn't want anything to do with
his father or his father's Quirk he
actually tried to suppress his Firebase
powers and Focus only on the ice powers
instead thankfully Shoto did eventually
reconcile with both his father and the
fire side of his Quirk and he then
started using his fire-based powers it
took him a while to get used to actually
using the fire side of his Quirk and he
spent a lot of time trying to alternate
between ice and fire in order to gain
full control of both aspects of his
Quirk Shoto has a resistance to both
extreme cold and extreme heat and
eventually he learns to use the two
sides of his Quirk so well that he can
actually combine both into a single
attack Shoto developed a technique
called phosphor which enables him to
channel both Fire and Ice throughout his
entire circulatory system and fuse the
two halves of his Quirk into a single
ability he is then able to create a
unique form of flame known as cold fire
which allows him to both burn and freeze
his opponents at the same time the move
also has defensive capabilities as it
can repel other attacks using its unique
combination of ice and heat even before
he learns to combine them both sides of
shoto's Quirk are extremely strong and I
won't go into all of his Feats here
because it will take a long time to
cover it all suffice it to say that with
his ice side he can instantly generate
entire waves and walls of ice that can
freeze entire buildings in seconds with
his Fireside he can create massive walls
of flame and heat so intense that it can
literally melt steel
initially overusing his eyesight would
drastically lower the temperature in
that side of his body and cause
frostbite and other injuries and
overusing his Fireside would make that
side of his body too hot causing
overheating and exhaustion luckily
shoto's commitment to training both
sides of his Quirk eventually allows him
to use Fire and Ice to balance each
other out reducing the negative effects
of both Fire and Ice on his body Shoto
is another one of those characters with
too many named ultimate moves to cover
in detail basically they're all really
strong and the more that the story
progresses the stronger they become also
the more Shoto learns to use both sides
of his Quirk at the same time the more
his ultimate moves begin fusing fire and
ice-based Powers
then we have toru hagakure also known as
the stealth hero invisible girl who sits
in seat number 16. her Quirk is called
invisibility and the name is pretty
self-explanatory it is a mutant type
Quirk that renders the user's entire
body invisible and it cannot be turned
off Toto's Quirk is obviously great for
moving around undetected whether you
want to sneak up on an enemy spy on them
or just complete secret missions without
being seen that said for total to be
completely invisible she has to be
completely naked because any clothes
that she puts on will be visible on her
body Toto's Quirk also has the ability
to manipulate light which suggests that
the entire Quirk May function on the
basis of light manipulation in short her
body automatically refracts light in a
way that hides her appearance to the
naked eye using light manipulation toru
can use her invisible body as a
magnifying lens of sorts which allows
her to warp the light around her into
bright spot parks that can temporarily
blind people this move is called warp
refraction she can also use her body to
redirect other light-based attacks such
as for example aoyama's Naval laser due
to both her invisibility and her ability
to redirect light toru can be an
extremely useful part of a hero team the
fact that she has to be completely naked
to be invisible means that Todo can't
really wear protective gear so she is
vulnerable to being hurt if she finds
herself on dangerous terrain or if she
finds herself in extreme temperature
conditions like scorching heat or
freezing cold on top of that if she is
hit by a visible substance such as paint
her silhouette will then be revealed
then she will no longer be invisible for
most of the series we had no idea what
Toto actually looked like because she
was always invisible but we did
eventually get a partial face reveal in
chapter 337 of the manga we then got a
full face reveal on the cover of chapter
368.
in seat number 17 we have the great
explosion murder God Dynamite himself
although he's sometimes referred to as
katsuki bakugo bakugou's emitter type
Quirk is called explosion and it enables
him to produce a special type of sweat
from his palms that has properties
similar to nitroglycerin essentially
instead of normal sweat bakugou produces
an explosive liquid and he uses it to
create explosions of different sizes and
intensities the explosions are extremely
powerful and they deal a great deal of
damage to both opponents and structures
fortunately for bakugou he himself is
immune to the effects of his own
explosion so he doesn't have to worry
about blowing himself up by accident the
explosions become stronger the more that
bakugou sweats so his Square can
actually become more powerful during a
longer and more challenging battle the
more intense the battle becomes the more
bakugou will sweat as a result which for
him is actually an asset explosion can
be effective at both close range and
long range and in has a lot going for it
Beyond its impressive offensive
capabilities for example Baku can
actually use his explosions to propel
himself through the air and in general
he can use the explosions to increase
the speed and efficacy of his movement
due to the explosive nature of his Quirk
bakugou does have to be careful about
collateral damage it is very easy for
his explosions to get out of control and
do unintended damage to the surrounding
area bakugo's hero costume and
especially his Grenadier bracers support
items allow him to have better control
of his explosions while also making them
stronger and more intense these items
enable bakugou to store his sweat in
very specific doses which means that he
can produce overpowered explosions
without losing control of them and
without hurting others bakugou is
another character with way too many
moves to cover individually but it's
important to note that bakugo is very
creative with his Quirk and he has
developed a large number of effective
combat tactics using his quirk's
abilities bakugou can do a super powered
narutaran propelled by his explosions or
he can do a large direct blast or he can
do multiple large or small blasts he can
do scattered blasts that are weaker and
concentrated blasts that are stronger he
can use his exposures to Propel himself
into the air and then attack his
opponent with mid-air bombardments and
much much more his most recent ultimate
move is called Howitzer impact cluster
and it is his most powerful attack yet
with the help of a new support item
called strafe Panzer bakugou uses his
explosions to launch himself upwards and
then spin himself through the air after
that he unleashes a massive barrage of
explosions that spray Devastation all
around him turning the battlefield into
a freaking war zone imagine like a
tornado made of explosions and that's
kind of what it is
next up is seat number 18 where we find
the one and only izuku midoriya AKA Deku
Deku was born quirkless but he wanted
desperately to become a hero even though
he didn't stand much of a chance in a
world where about 80 percent of the
population had a quirk having a quirk is
obviously a huge advantage to anyone
trying to become a hero and so Deku was
a massive Underdog but he got lucky
because he met toshinoriyagi AKA all
might and all might became convinced
that Deku was the perfect person to
inherit his Quirk one for all one for
all is a special Quirk that can be
transferred from one person to another
and the transfer can happen only if the
current user willingly allows the new
user to consume some of their DNA after
Deku eats a strand of olmite's hair he
becomes the ninth user of one for all
one for all is an emitter type Quirk
that was created by the fusion of a
powerful stockpiling Quirk and another
Quirk which I allowed its user to
transfer it onto someone else the
stockpiling ability allows the user to
build up incredible amounts of power in
their body and this gives them
superhuman strength speed durability and
Agility what makes all for one extra
strong is the fact that it has been
transferred from one person to another
over the course of many decades and with
each new user more power was stockpiled
inside The Quirk and so one for all is
much stronger now than it was initially
and it just keeps getting stronger this
stockpiled power can be spread out
evenly throughout the body or it can be
focused into a specific body part like
your arm when you're punching or your
leg when you're kicking now because the
user has so much power available to them
they first need to train intensely in
order to learn to control the Quirk at
first Deku would severely injure himself
every time he tried to use his Quirk and
we're talking serious injuries like
broken bones it was only after
undergoing rigorous training under the
mentorship of both almight and Gran
Torino the Deku learned to control the
percentage of power he was using when he
activated one for all and this helped
keep him out of the hospital at least
sometimes because let's face it he does
still end up in the hospital a lot
another thing that makes one for all
truly unique is that the vestiges and
Quirk factors of all its former users
are still contained within the Quirk and
after a while Deku learns to actively
communicate with the vestiges of all the
former users they are then able to guide
him as he works on fully mastering the
one for all quirk in fact Deku
eventually becomes the first one for all
user in history to gain the ability to
unlock the quirks of all the former
users and so he goes from being
quirkless to inheriting one for all to
then unlocking six other quirks in
addition to one for all the quirks that
once belonged to the former users of the
one for all Quirk these additional
quirks include black whip which lets
Deku generate black tendrils from his
body and then use them to attack or
restrain an opponent float which allows
him to levitate through the air smoke
screen which enables him to generate
smoke all around him danger sense which
is a lot like a spidey sense and it lets
him identify threats in the surrounding
area fajin which allows him to build up
kinetic energy and release superhuman
bursts of strength and speed and finally
gear shift which allows him to shift the
speed of anything he touches literally
defying the laws of physics now of
course these are just quick summaries of
what the quirks do and there is a lot
more that can be said about each of them
in fact I would need an entire 30 plus
minute video to break down all of deku's
different quirks and all of the former
users of one for all thankfully I
already made that 30 plus minute video
so if you want to Deep dive into one for
all and its former users I will link
that video in the description and in the
pinned comment so feel free to check it
out the main power of the Quirk all for
one is to steal the quirks of others and
the villain all for one has been trying
to steal one for all for many many
generations but because one for all can
only be transferred with the current
user's consent all for one has always
failed in his attempt to steal it this
makes one for all an incredibly precious
weapon in the multi-generational battle
to stop all for one unsurprisingly one
for all has way too many named moves and
we can't talk about them all
individually although many of them are
named after U.S states or cities and
they are often directly related to how
much of one for all's full power is
being released again if you want a more
detailed breakdown of one for all check
out my full video on it Link in the
description
in seat number 19 we have best boy
minoruminata you know the guy who throws
sticky grape-shaped balls from his head
the name of his Quirk is Popoff and it
is a mutant type Quirk that works at
medium range basically minata produces
sticky purple balls on his head and he
can rip them off and throw them at
people and things the balls will stick
to anything except for minata's own body
they actually bounce off of his body and
as soon as he rips one ball off his head
a new one will replace it right away
minata can use his Quirk to make his
opponent stick to something or to each
other essentially trapping them in place
because the balls bounce off of mineta's
body instead of sticking to it he can
actually use the balls as many
trampolines to increase his own speed
and maneuverability so if he places a
ball on the ground and then jumps
directly on it he will bounce high up
into the air and if he places a bunch of
balls on the ground in front of him then
he can Bounce from one ball to the other
with great Speed and Agility he can also
attach a bunch of balls to each other in
order to create bigger traps and you can
even stick them one on top of the other
to create a whip of swords that he can
then use on the battlefield this move is
called minata beads because of course it
is and it is one of the several named
ultimate moves that he possesses others
include a gray brush which involves me
to tell rushing an enemy while throwing
a bunch of balls at them super great
brush which involves him launching a
large number of balls from the air at an
opponent below Vineyard which involves
Mina to attaching a rope to his balls in
order to create a snare man that did not
come out right grape buckler which
involves minata making a powerful Shield
by sticking a bunch of his balls
together and grape pinky combo
minatabones a combo move between minata
and Mina ashido Mina task work is
clearly the strongest in all of class 1a
but it does have a few weaknesses the
level of stickiness is dependent on
minata's own health and the stickiness
can last anywhere from a few hours to an
entire day also if minata pops too many
balls from his head in a short period of
time he starts bleeding from his scalp
and finally after best boy minata we
have best girl Momo Yao yorozu the class
Vice representative who sits in seat
number 20. Momo has an emitter type
Quirk called creation that allows her to
create objects from any part of her body
and these objects can include anything
from basic weapons and tools to
sophisticated cannons and missiles no
matter how complex an object is Momo is
able to create it as long as she
understands the atomic structure of the
object she just needs to imagine the
parts that are required to make it then
the raw materials that are required to
construct it and finally the coating the
objects can emerge anywhere on Momo's
skin but she needs to keep the skin bare
meaning she can't cover up that part of
her skin with clothing creation
functions by breaking down Momo's fat on
a molecular level and reusing it as
materials that form the objects she
creates so Momo's ability to keep
creating objects depends on how much fat
she has stored up inside her body
meaning that she has to eat a huge
amount of food in order to use her Quirk
effectively but if she does have enough
fat stored up Momo has the ability to
create massive objects even objects that
are bigger than her own body such as a
fully functioning catapult although
getting to this point took training and
commitment Momo's Creations are
generally considered to be Flawless
copies of The Originals due to the
absolutely incredible versatility of her
Quirk Momo is able to fight at close
range mid-range and long range all she
has to do is create a suitable weapon or
tool for the range in question and since
she can make everything from a short
sword to a cannon she doesn't have to
worry about range related limitations
but although creation is incredibly
powerful and versatile and it is easily
one of the best quirks ever in my
opinion it is not without some drawbacks
Momo does need time to create objects
and so having to fight suddenly without
prep time makes things more difficult
this is especially the case with
producing more complex objects because
their creation requires more time than
the creation of simple objects and as I
mentioned earlier Momo needs to have a
strong understanding of the atomic
composition of everything she creates
and she needs to have enough fat stored
up in her body in order to create that
object over using her Quirk can lead her
to becoming too weak and frail to
continue fighting Momo has a named
ultimate move called yaoyoruzu's lucky
bag and this involves Momo creating a
cannon that shoots out a bag that
contains a bunch of useful support items
that her allies can use in battle and
this move really showcases what a great
asset Momo's Quirk can be in any team
situation Momo's exceptional
intelligence impressive strategic
ability and incredible Quirk make her
one of the best team players in all of
mha and she demonstrated her ability to
work effectively with other Heroes and
hero students multiple times throughout
the series the scene in which she and a
bunch of Heroes and hero students
attempt to stop a raging gigantom machia
by putting him to sleep is probably the
single best example of this
and that is it all 20 quirks from class
1a explained with updated information
all the way up to the final Arc of the
story needless to say this video turned
out to be far longer than the 13 minute
video on all the quirks that we made
over five years ago when there was far
less information available about the
quirks themselves thank you guys so much
for watching and don't forget to check
out my detailed breakdown of one for all
and all its former users and their
quirks Link in the description if you
made it this far into the video then
congratulations you just heard me say
over 10 000 words yes that is how long
this video turned out to be but I really
hope that having all of this information
here in one place will be useful to you
if it is then please leave a like and
comment right now to help me out with
that YouTube algorithm and if you are
one of the over 50 of people who watch
our videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet please do me a quick favor
and subscribe to anime uproar right now
subscribing on YouTube is come
completely free but it helps me out a
lot and if you really want to do me a
solid you can also hit that Bell and
select the option that says all that's
like an additional piece of insurance
that you won't miss our future videos
because YouTube refuses to recommend
them to you thanks again for your time
your support your likes and comments and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys